there's an undeniable pleasure in the
fantasy of tracking down and taking out
a monster and playing a hunter and
evolve is all about realizing that dream
now not satisfied with merely letting
four people unload their clips into
something much bigger than them Tula
Rock Studios has designed four very
distinct classes for of all all of which
play wildly different than one another
that need to be played in cooperative
unity even within those classes there
are very distinct loadouts all going to
show you there's more than one way to
bring down a Goliath
I guess at the beginning of the end the
ideas were there you're ready to set to
you know start to make it happen what
was the concept of the hunters what was
the core thing that was essential to
sort of flushing them out the main thing
was getting them the tools that they
needed to actually take down this
massive monster and to make it deep
enough to get people to play like keep
them interested for extended period of
time so that was the main the main thing
is figuring out what those tools are and
how to actually fight this monster who
was not developed and designed
completely it already so it's like a
difficult problem solved when you don't
know how to fight this thing that isn't
built did you already she sort of the
four classes like what was kind of that
the strictures you were trying to work
with it it was all theorizing basically
just sitting around speculating on wall
what would you want to do how would you
stop this monster how would you fight
him and then we'd actually just build
them and implement them and test them in
a very early stage and see how it played
out and then the good ideas they just
kept getting develop further and further
and they became the things are actually
in the game
they may not be the most novel of the
aspect but the hunter you know just
based on proportions you know people
will be spending a lot of time playing
as them what was kind of the key
elements to make the hunter experience
memorable and special the first parts
obviously the gameplay and making sure
that the gear is there and the gear kind
of helps the co-op happen right every
every every class has a role an
important part to play and so there's
that aspect of it and then and then
there's the really the art side of it
which the video personalities you've got
the games that will sort of have the
generic guy right and we like having
characters that you can kind of fall in
love with and get to know we look for
like really strong archetypes there's a
fine line between archetype and
stereotype stereotype is a negative
thing archetype is sort of a celebration
the big thing is that we want the
characters to feel new and fresh but
also familiar and kind of comfortable
right like so when you look at Markov
and you hear him talk ok I get it he's
that he's the big boisterous you know
Russian guy who likes to fight I get
that one of the things that we decided
to do sort of later in the process was
kind of go a little bit stylized with
them not only does it make them easier
to sort of pick up in the game but it
also sort of exaggerated stare character
and reinforces that luff abilities
in in terms of developing out the
various hunters as time went on how much
of it was just kind of a moment of
inspiration and then trying to make that
work with inside the gameplay and how
much was as you are developing what the
monsters were like that it kind of
necessitated that other qualities be
demonstrated in the hunter to be there
such an interesting back and forth
between those two elements of the game
it's a merger of both constantly because
you you create a character and then you
play them for a while and you see how
the monster interacts with them and how
your teammates interact with him and he
just changes and adapts that way and
then like with bucket you just see what
their personalities are like and then
you push that further and try to make it
cooler and just come fear in funnier it
is kind of interesting that with the
characterizations and the aesthetics of
the characters that you know sort of the
more material aspect of them which is
what the gear is for each one there
seems to be quite a bit of harmony you
know Mark cops got it seems like the gun
that the markup should have so what we
did was he took all that big pile of
gear and we said okay what goes really
well you know with the lightning gun we
felt like our minds went really well
with that and we started piecing gear
together and that wound up sort of being
themes you know Lazarus having a silent
sniper rifle with the ability to cloak
and the ability to bring people back
from the dead leads to a very stealthy
character right I kind of arranged all
the gear in theme so all I knew was that
Markov skier was electricity based I had
no idea what the character might look
like or anything I just know that it's
electricity based right and then my job
is kind of done and I hand that off okay
well I get it this character is kind of
he's lightning theme he's electrical
theme you know and then you start
thinking about you know where can I take
that yeah okay look I couldn't take its
head off and send it off into the World
War II we had a lot of fun with bucket
four out of other all the characters I'd
say bucket probably has more than his
fair share of personality once the
character team decides we'd really like
to have a robot then it kind of comes
back as I cool if it's a robot we can do
crazy stuff like his arm could be a
rocket launcher and that sounds cool
again it goes back to us being 13 year
olds and being excited about like if I
was a robot I would want to have an arm
that could shoot rockets and I can find
my head around that would be awesome so
that's what we do apparently I'm pretty
good at this and then we also have you
know perks each you know hunter feels
like okay I want to be able to move
faster I want to be able to heal faster
that's a lot of variables to take into
account I mean when was the decision
that you wanted to give one more option
to the player to kind of really
distinguish their character I definitely
have seen advantages from it but boy did
you can add a lot for your head we see
teams collaborate sometimes and say okay
let's all take damage the extra damage /
and so they they know that they're sort
of sacrificing like armor or movement
speed or some other thing but they all
know that they're going to focus on
doing damage that round you know so
you'll see individuals make decisions
about what my favorite perk is but you
also see teams coordinating and coming
up with sort of these high-level
strategies which is really fun it just
adds to replayability can i play a
hundred rounds and still feel like
there's more stuff for me to try ideas
come from all over the place everybody's
playtesting game and then you find out
really cool ways to push it even further
here's awesome
obviously a lot of attention has to be
considered too like how a map works and
how it sort of maintains the fun but
when you have varying traversal methods
be at monster the jetpacks hey how did
you have to rethink approaching level
design we didn't know what would work
and what would be fun so we really were
starting at zero yeah we really wanted
the world to have that feeling of kind
of isolation so immediately you have
that feeling of like there's no way off
this planet
you